this video is sponsored by Squarespace
you know what's powerful websites they
can be anything a place to learn a place
to meet people or a place to find
something to buy no matter what though
for people who want to create having a
website is a must and that's why I'm
excited about Squarespace so excited in
fact that I made my own website using
Squarespace to host my information on
kind of like an online resume of sorts
and listen if I can do it anyone can
they have tons of templates to work off
of and customize to your heart's content
and you can even host your videos on
your own site to remonetize them or list
your products with a few simple clicks
and keep track of everything with their
intuitive analytics if you're at all
interested in having a website of your
own I highly recommend checking out
squarespace.com and building your own
website with their free trial and when
you're happy with it go to
squarespace.com Bandit to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain so what are you waiting for
fellow website owner and now on to the
video
for over three years the only thing we
actually knew about the sequel to breath
of the wild was the fact that it was in
development there was so much that we
didn't know about the game that it was
that very essence of Unknowing that
spread across the fan base and gave rise
to a lot of new YouTube channels that
made videos about the sequel with the
humble Yours Truly being one of them but
in a way I feel like all of that changed
this week because on Tuesday we didn't
get another vague trailer that somehow
reveals a lot but at the same time
reveals nothing at all we instead got
our first actual look at the gameplay in
tears of the kingdom yes it does look
similar to breath of the wild in many
ways but it's also completely new in a
lot of ways too oh yeah and it also
confirmed the zonai's importance in the
story for the first time so you know
that's cool but the biggest takeaway
from the gameplay spot the part that
stuck out to me the most was the
Showcase of Link's new abilities fuse is
one of the wildest simple Concepts that
I've ever seen realized in a video game
which kind of seems to be Zelda's
calling card these days like when they
said Hey what if link could climb in
breath of the wild boom mind-blowing
Ascend or as I like to call it Rock swim
makes me very excited for all the new
dungeon crawling possibilities an ultra
hand AKA Sticky Fingers is insane and
definitely not going to lead to any
raunchy Creations from the fan base
what's this someone already
conceptualized a phallicopter oh
wonderful but the ability that stuck out
to me the most was the first one that
was also shown off in a previous trailer
the one called recall not only is the
concept cool because it essentially
turns link into Doctor Strange which
also opens up an insane amount of
possibilities for gameplay but it's icon
that little kanji looking symbol in the
top left when it's being used is also
present on Link's new Zone I hand when
he uses it this is important and you
want to know why because if you'll
recall when onuma announced the infamous
delay to tears of the kingdom last year
we were given another little bitty shot
of Link facing some glowing yellow orb
in holding out the mangled master sword
in its direction and if you look closely
you can see that not only is his hand
glowing yellow which it does when using
the recall ability but the symbol on his
hand is straight up also the recall
symbol proving that that's what he's
doing to the master sword it's a bit
hard to see but here let me use the
magical powers of Premiere Pro's 3D
image manipulation to help with the
visual see every Zelda fan out there
automatically assumed that whatever link
is doing here has got to be in some way
repairing the master sword I mean we
even see the repaired tip of the master
sword in tears of the Kingdom's logo
repaired with the same blue green zone
eye color might I add which implies that
it will be a zonai power that repairs it
with this in mind I'm about 98 certain
that link is recalling whatever this
golden orb is Into The Master Sword
which glows and responds the question is
what is that golden orb and how is it
connected to the rest of the sky islands
or Sky rule as I like to call them well
keep in mind this is all just my
speculation because spoiler alert the
game isn't actually out yet but I wanted
to cover a few possibilities for what
this recalling method might mean for the
master sword and even skyrule as a whole
something that's important to note is
the fact that none of the islands of Sky
rule are present in the sky before
Ganondorf resurrects this is made
apparent in two of The Game's trailers
the first one which straight up shows
Hyrule without a sky rule as the castle
is Lifting and the second one which
again shows no floating islands just
after the castle has been lifted into
the air this implies to me that the
appearance of Sky Rule's many islands is
going to be directly related to whatever
is happening here and there are a bunch
of things happening here Zelda's falling
and who knows where she's gonna land
ganondorf's cracking back to life and a
huge tendril of ultra malice shoots out
towards link who is wielding the master
sword which has been corrupted by malice
there are a lot of moving pieces here
all of which are enough to Merit hours
upon hours of speculation in and of
themselves but for the purposes of
explaining recall and the master sword
we'll focus on what happens to the
master sword in the first place the
master sword being corrupted is
extremely strange and shouldn't actually
be possible from its conception way back
in the first days of skyward Swords
speaking in terms of lore here in it has
always been the blade of Evil's Bane it
is so allergic to Darkness and evil
powers in general that it can even
oppose the power of the Triforce itself
when it's used for evil like when it
cleansed Link's dark curse in Twilight
Princess or when it successfully killed
a Triforce empowered individual also in
Twilight Princess the Triforce may be
omnipotent but even it has to answer to
the sheer righteous power of the master
sword that being said it's been
corrupted and not just corrupted but
broken into pieces as far as what could
even be able to do this to the master
sword that's another topic for another
day which might not come before the
release of the game since it's coming
pretty soon now or maybe it will and you
should probably be subscribed to the
channel just in case it does hint hint
for this video though I'd like to
present two thoughts about what the
glowing orbs might be that link recalls
into the blade and where all the spiral
Islands might have come from and let's
start with that first one since the
master sword is clearly missing some
length the question is where are its
pieces that have been broken off well
since link is recall hauling this
glowing orb into the blade what if the
orb is a piece of the blade that was
broken off the sword does look
discolored and has a bunch of holes in
it which could mean that the pieces that
have broken off of it have instead been
eaten away like in some sort of acid but
perhaps that doesn't actually matter
perhaps the broken pieces of the master
sword are immaterial and are instead
more Essences of its righteous power
like this golden orb sitting in front of
link and once recalled into the blade
will slowly but surely rebuild it and
restore it to its former glory and then
some perhaps the second possibility
about the islands his appearance would
be what if skyro is the sacred realm now
hear me out I know that this idea isn't
new by any means I mean people were
noticing these scarily accurate
similarities between the islands of Sky
Rule and this particular depiction of
the Sacred realm from A Link to the Past
right off the bat which by the way is
also known as the golden land and
without Numa directly saying just this
week that these golden yellow trees are
only present on the sky islands the
possibility of Sky rule being the golden
land just skyrocketed no pun intended
okay maybe a little pun intended some of
the islands do appear to have tree roots
growing along the edges which implies
some of them might have lifted off of
the ground but that doesn't necessarily
discredit the sacred realm Theory since
we know the sacred realm is a copy of
our realm hence the Dark World and a
link to the past which is the corrupted
sacred realm and mirrors our own but
okay before I go down rabbit holes of
speculation about how the zonai fit into
all of this and whatnot let's dial it
back to the master sword what connects
the sword to the islands well recall
once again with me if you will just how
many times the master sword has led to
the opening of another land or area or
power in the series in Ocarina of Time
the master sword opened the way to the
sacred realm which was proven by the
word of rauru and for those of you who
know how rauru is significant here I'll
give you a virtual wink although we've
never been directly shown the physical
aspect of the master sword being the key
we still know it is or was at least in
the Wind Waker the master sword unlocks
Hyrule out of its stasis as well as
ganondorf's full power and in Twilight
Princess it unlocks the path into the
Temple of Light I mean the Temple of
Time Dungeon so what if this breaking of
the master sword and tears of the
Kingdom somehow unlocks skyrule which
link must explore and Traverse in order
to find the broken Essences of the blade
of Evil's Bane and recall them back into
the sword with the help of the zonai and
their mysterious big lady you gotta
admit it's possible and would actually
make a ton of sense and something
similar already happened with piecing
the Triforce of Courage back together in
the Wind Waker but what do you think are
these orbs the broken shards of the
master sword are the islands of skyrill
unlocked after the blades corruption or
is it something else entirely let me
know in the comments below and thank you
so much for watching if you'd be so kind
please consider leaving a like on the
video if you like talking about tears of
the kingdom and subscribe if you haven't
already to stick around for much much
more tears of the Kingdom coverage to
come huge thanks as always to my Bandit
crew of which I have the name of Alex
Yvette s to welcome you guys make my day
every day and I cannot thank you enough
that's all I've got for this one so be
sure to follow me on my socials and I'll
see you next time the his Bandit signing
out
[Music]